is an alternative name for this the
greatest common divisor it's a different
wedding but it means exactly the same
thing so on the right you'll write or
highest common so I hope you can see
even though it's like what my big fancy
words they mean the same thing
highest and greatest they mean the same
thing divisor and factor in this context
all means is something you can divide by
you know numbers like this 660 323 is
the divisor it's a factor I can divided
through third okay sorry a statistic
same 23 and 29
if both factors they both devices in
this case now what should you polish
you're gonna put your pens down and look
up I want you to remember I gave you a
metaphor right the star of when we
looked at primes and competent numbers I
gave you a metaphor I said in chemistry
they're true four kinds of things and
they're kinda like plans in coal
business do you remember what the two
things were they don't remember
mikheil you come back yeah and yes very
good you're gonna on the tip your tongue
right elements and compounds they kind
of like tribes and compasses yeah it's
like I've got elements like hydrogen and
oxygen carbon and I can combine them to
make different things and that's exactly
what we're seeing if you see this right
here all of these primes
these are these elements and if I
combine them in a particular way I'll
get these different composit numbers now
what we're going to look at is that I
really want to know sometimes there are
different compounds right which have
elements in common
just like there are sometimes composite
numbers that have prime numbers in
common okay the reason why that's really
valuable is you don't understand
I hope you remember I gave you some
examples of compounds last time right
does anyone remember what this one is
it's me you and HCl what it is yeah it's
all right
sodium chloride it's certainly the
chlorine you're putting together you get
salt cool not one of the top I didn't
mention does anyone remember what that H
stands for it's um it's hydrogen so
hydrogen and chlorine right you get
hydrochloric acid that's the stuff in
your stomach that's eating up all that
through the day that reset so I heard
good reason
okay now hydrochloric acid and salt
right you can clearly see they have
something in common that's what this is
talking about right and understanding
what's in common is really useful right
one of the things that you guys will
learn impression is that chlorine is one
of the most reactive things in the
universe right whatever chlorine touches
something it like crabs on or it makes a
reaction happen that's why in your
stomach it's pretty good at breaking
down food and in a food it's pretty good
at like white binding all the flavors
are there and enhancing them that's why
we use some questions
yes yeah yeah there's a lot of different
things happening there but the chlorine
that's in a pool like chlorine is doing
its job making the the pool clean
precisely because of the same property
it grabs onto like bacteria and might it
breaks it down all I kind of thing right
so that's why it keeps the same kind of
idea also why I feel like me and you
have like X my like bad skin you go into
the pore you come out now or later and
everything's peachy because the
chlorines bound to your skin and taking
some of the skin with it right so
chlorine it does that thank you okay so
so humor some people get upset me like
why are you wearing a science teacher
was like them I'm gonna pause now I'll
let someone else like Wikipedia or your
science teacher onto that particular
question all I wanted to point out
though is if you know what a a compound
is made up you didn't understand some
his properties and if you understand
what a number a composite number is made
on you can also understand it better you
can understand that there are things in
common and that's what this is about
now what we're looking for is what is
the greatest common divisor between
these two numbers or the highest common
factor in other words I'm looking for
chlorine I'm looking for the thing
that's in common between those two
numbers now some of the something that's
easy to work out for instance I can see
right away if I remember my divisibility
tests there's an easy number to spot
that's less than 10 that we're
definitely going to go to this didn't
even tell me right away yeah fine
okay five right how do we know how did
Darrin spot so quickly that was gonna be
five someone else
okay so this one ends in five it's going
to be doing bye-bye and this one ends in
zebra also divisible by five right so
that's good that's a start
however maybe it's divisible by a big
enough mainly have more in common than
just fine okay so the way we're going to
work this out is just like we had here
with the factor tree we're going to do a
factor tree on each of these boil it
down just like these get boiled down
like what's what's this made on and
we're going to work out exactly what all
the things apart so can I ask you I'll
give you a bit of a head start for these
two numbers would you please draw for me
a factor tree for each one a factor tree
for each one and then once you've got a
factor tree use that to write out the
prime decomposition what are all the
primes that go into this okay can you do
that point okay now I haven't finished
yet I'm not done but I've gotten the
first step done you can see I've got my
tree there now your tree could you
pretend on don't tell me about would you
think your tree looks a bit different to
mine like just not as you chose a
different yeah heads up good thank you
hands down most of you now one of the
reasons why is for instance 360 I could
do the same thing I did over here and
divide by two far as I know at 360 is an
even number okay and that's fine but you
might notice right see over here my tree
is really long like it took me ages to
get down to the smallest number here
okay whereas the trees here we've never
been upside down but the trees you're
quite sure I didn't have to go that many
steps what I would advise you do is
think of the biggest numbers that you
can divide it okay because that will
make the whole leaf tree process quicker
for you and you'll probably seek to
never the same mathematicians are lazy
we're always looking for them
efficient so you can see hands up do you
agree with my my actual result at the
end hands up yeah are we okay with that
good thank you
so let's write that prime decomposition
let's write it down together how many
twos do you see yep great so I'm gonna
write two cute what's the next prime
yeah yeah yep sure
uh-huh so I've got the next one here but
I'm gonna try and go in order like
numerical order that's everybody would
you pretend very good because there are
not just one free but there are two of
those that we swear and then we come to
the five right okay there we go so that
is how I write 360 okay you didn't have
heard HCl and NaCl right this this is
the equivalent for this that's what's
made oh okay yeah now I'll point out
right what a great things about this is
we all ended up at the same spot
I seen you went through the right way
but these lots of different pods there
okay your tree might look different but
we end up with the same crimes in fact
that's a really important property of
numbers you always end up with the same
time lastly it looks like I've got how
many threes 4/5 so I'm gonna write 3 to
the power 4 multiplied by 5 and I'm done
okay now remember what my original
question was I wanted to work out well
what's the biggest number the greatest
or the highest number that's a factor of
both of these right every single one of
these every number on the board is a
factor of the number in its tree right
so for example of anyone a9 v MF at
disappointed 5 on 10 + 3 + 9 they're all
factors of 360 so what's the biggest
possible number I can cram into both of
them okay now couple of remember you
told me right at the beginning before we
did any of this you all said 5 right
remember that what that means is on both
of my trees
5
is there do you notice that makes two
fives in common fives not the only thing
your comment though isn't what else do I
say okay I see a three feet up three and
there's another three over here that
matches up too okay
am I finished now there's one more right
there is well yeah okay I could say nine
but I'm gonna try and do it in terms of
the prime numbers because they're the
ones I came with and they'll be no
repeats right so in addition to this
three here I've got two threes they do
see that now have a look have a look at
the Prime's are there any more Prime's
that are in both of them
that I haven't messed up yet I think I'm
done right do you see I've got more
threes here but there are no more threes
over heat imagine yeah
I've got a whole bunch of two's here but
there are no cheese over here to magic
so therefore now I can conclude I can
say do you remember we use those three
dots to indicate therefore so I'm gonna
say there for the greatest common
divisor or the highest common factor I'm
just going to write GCD the greatest
common divisor the greatest common
divisor has two threes and a 5 2 3 and a
5 what is 3 squared times 5 3 squared 3
squared is 9 and so nine times five
years through 45 45 apparently is the
greatest common divisor now this time if
you drive a bear I will actually get you
calculator just to check right what is
400 watt divided by 4 fine what do you
get yes
nine times for you and hopefully if
we've done this right this can also be
divided into 25 right how many 45s is it
in fact you might be able to see even
without a calculator yeah it's gonna be
eight right do you see why it has to be
a even without calculator yeah yeah very
good that's the difference between this
right keys 8:45 and here's the next 45
90 okay so we're done you can see that's
it you there's no bigger number you can
divide into both of those
just like chlorine is the biggest thing
okay